it's show time
the year is 1979 and the los angeles
lakers are if you can believe it a down
and out team welcome to sunny los
angeles great for tans [ __ ] for fans but
the new owner has a vision if there's
two things that make me believe in god
it's sex and basketball welcome to the
world of winning time the new hbo series
about the rise of the lakers dynasty
first pick the 1979 nba draft the los
angeles lakers select irvin
magic johnson
i'm rodney barnes an executive producer
and writer on the show and the host of
the official winning time companion
podcast from hbo hyper object industries
and pineapple street studios
[Music]
over the next 10 weeks i'll be breaking
down each episode of winning time
taking you behind the scenes and talking
shop and basketball with the show's
creators stars and collaborators
everyone from executive producer and
director adam mckay when you get that
fast break free freewheeling creative
style going it's much harder to game
plan again so these teams started
winning
and they were winning with style and
flair and right in the middle of that
were the showtime lakers to show runner
max bornstein i hope that one of the
things people come away with is not just
an appreciation for the people that they
know the magics the creams the pat
riley's but knowing and respecting and
having a new appreciation for the
characters and the people that they've
never heard of
to the breakout star who plays magic
johnson himself quincy isaiah i feel
like sometimes i have to remind myself
like yo you're doing this you here
because you deserve to be here but if i
feel like an imposter alright well let's
work until i'm not
and along the way we'll learn how the
lakers came to be the center of sports
and celebrity in 1980s la if you're a
human being with two eyes and a heart
this game this industry makes you feel
good what industry sweat socks no
show business it's gonna be exciting
winning time the rise of the lakers
dynasty premieres sunday march 6th on
hbo max episode 1 of this podcast drops
right after that be sure to subscribe to
winning time the official companion
podcast new episodes drop every sunday
get them on hbo max or wherever you
listen
you